MICHELLE WILLIAMS:
Welcome to The Forum,
livestreamed worldwide
from the Leadership Studio
at the Harvard T.H. Chan
School of Public Health.
I'm Dean Michelle Williams.
The Forum is a collaboration
between the Harvard Chan School
and independent news media.
Each program features
a panel of experts
addressing some of today's most
pressing public health issues.
The Forum is one way
the school advances
the frontiers of
public health and makes
scientific insights accessible
to policymakers and the public.
I hope you find this program
engaging and informative.
Thank you for joining us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
Hi, everyone.
My name is Margot Sanger-Katz.
I'm a correspondent
at the New York Times,
and I'm your moderator today.
I want to introduce our panel.
To my immediate
right is Bob Blendon,
who's a professor
of health policy
and political analysis at
the Harvard T.H. Chan School
of Public Health and the
Harvard Kennedy School.
Next is Eric Schneider,
who's the senior vice
president for
policy and research
at the Commonwealth Fund.
Bob Master, who's the
founder and former president
and chief executive officer of
the Commonwealth Care Alliance.
And joining us remotely
is Toyin Ajayi,
who is the chief health officer
and a co-founder of CityBlock,
and I know also a Boston alum.
So this event is being
presented in collaboration
with the Commonwealth Fund,
and we are streaming live
on The Forum, on
Facebook and on YouTube.
We are going to have a
brief Q&A at the end,
and so those of you
in the audience,
prepare good questions.
But those of you who
are watching remotely
can also email your questions
to theforum@hsph.harvard.edu.
And you can also
participate in a live chat
that's happening on The
Forum's website right now.
So to come to our topic
today, if we really
want to understand how the
health care system is working,
I think it makes a
lot of sense to see
how it's working for the
people who really need it.
And I was surprised when
we began this project
to learn that there
has never been
a major survey of the seriously
ill people who use the health
care system the most.
So this year, with
the Commonwealth Fund
and the Harvard School of Public
Health, we surveyed nearly 14--
sorry, we surveyed
1,495 people who
had real health problems,
multiple hospitalizations
and doctor's visits, and often
many other needs besides.
And some of what we found
was pretty disappointing.
Patients said they
were receiving
care that was confusing,
conflicting, dispiriting,
and included medical errors.
They also reported substantial
financial distress,
despite health
insurance coverage that
was supposed to protect them.
So we're going to take a closer
look at the poll results today.
We'll also talk about some
of the less obvious costs
of serious illness, costs
that don't necessarily
appear on medical bills but
still make it hard for people.
And we want talk about
some possible solutions,
so it won't all
be doom and gloom,
including programs that our
panelists are working on
to try to address these issues.
So first, let's watch a
clip from the US Department
of Health and
Human Services that
brings home the financial
impact of serious illness.
RICHARD KNIGHT: I
am Richard Knight
of New Carrollton, Maryland.
Life before I was
diagnosed was very good.
I was running my own business.
I was president of a
Boys and Girls Club.
1996, I went to get
some life insurance.
I had the blood work, urine
test, and I was rejected.
And as it turned out, I had
impending kidney failure.
My kidneys continued to
deteriorate until 2004,
when they shut down completely.
I went to the emergency room.
I began dialysis.
I was 51, 2006, when
I had my transplant.
I had an amazing recovery.
I was taking immunity
suppressant medication
that was fairly expensive.
I am looking at a couple
hundred dollars a month
copay, even with Medicare.
And first I have to pay for
the deductible every year.
I probably won't retire,
and one of the reasons
is because of the cost
of the medications
that I will constantly
have to pay for.
The fact that the government
is looking at the cost of drugs
is a plus.
I'm very encouraged by that.
SPEAKER 1: American
Patients First.
hhs.gov/drugpricing.
Produced by the US Department
of Health and Human Services
at taxpayer expense.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
So we just saw
the story of this
one patient who
is facing a lot of
financial obstacles
even though he got this
amazing organ transplant that
changed his life.
Bob, I know we had
a lot of questions
and a lot of answers in the poll
about people facing these kinds
of financial stresses.
Can you talk a little bit
about what the results were?
BOB BLENDON: So we'll
do this quickly,
but the biggest finding is,
for 50 years in this country,
we've been debating how to
help people who aren't insured.
And the assumption is,
once you get them the card,
they are protected for
the rest of their lives.
And we're going to
take you in a world
where serious little
people with insurance,
including Medicare, are
facing staggering bills.
It has nothing to do
with the dialogue we've
been having for 50 years.
You cross the Rubicon.
Now, you're safe.
So let's just do
this very quickly.
First it buried in
every story about--
first slide-- health
care in America
is one in six people
who are extraordinarily
ill over a three-year period.
And so the people in
our sample, 100% of them
were hospitalized
at least twice,
said they had a serious illness.
A quarter of them were
hospitalized five times
in three years.
They were mostly seeing
five doctors or more.
So you talk about
information coordination.
They are taking five or
more prescription drugs.
And just to show, as we'll show
in a minute, insured America,
one in 10 had $50,000 a year of
prescription medication bills.
And these are people
who, in fact, say
they're seriously ill, and they
have one of the major killers.
So these are not
routine patients at all.
Let's just take a
look at what happens.
Next slide.
So the gray bars are all 91%
of people-- good news-- had
a health insurance policy.
Wow, I can feel good about that.
So here it is.
I have a health
insurance policy.
53% of people with a
health insurance policy
had serious medical bills.
They had problems paying it.
And so a third were hospital.
But I'm insured.
Third, prescription
drugs, emergency rooms.
These are not stories
about the uninsured.
These are stories of people
who have an insurance card.
All through our poll,
each section we ask you,
what worries you most?
Mostly, I don't know
how I can pay for this.
Suddenly, they're being told
that this policy that they're
lying in a bed with is
not going to do that.
Next slide, please.
So take quickly.
So if you just look at the
gray bars, I have insurance.
My family feels reassured.
36% of the insured people
used up all their savings
as a result of having this.
They had insurance.
21% couldn't pay for basic
necessities, having insurance,
and lost the job.
And we'll get back to this
in a minute, most people who
work in America have
short-term sick benefits.
Guess what?
If I'm not sick over
these periods of time,
my benefits run out.
And my job sends
me a loving note
about you may not be able
to continue for this.
So we have that.
And the last slide,
very quickly.
So all of us have
stories that may
have played that role, where a
friend or family member, when
you go home from the hospital,
takes care of you for a while.
But these are people
who have long a whiles.
So this is the
financial experience
of the person who
cared for you at home.
Not you, them.
So one in four of
those people had
significant financial
problems because they
had to cut back on the rest of
their lives, and 21% of them
just said I had to care
for someone at home,
I have a lower income
as a result of that.
So just the two
takeaways from here.
Now that we're moving away
from the uninsured debate,
there's a serious problem if
you're seriously ill about
whether or not your
insurance will cover you.
Secondly, sick days,
which at Harvard
may be terrific for as
long as you want to be out,
are not that good
for other people.
And if you have a
long-term illness,
you start running
out of your sick days
and you have an
inability of keeping
your financial viability.
Eric?
ERIC SCHNEIDER: Great.
Thank you.
And I'll take the next slide.
BOB BLENDON: It's not
exactly great, but it's.
ERIC SCHNEIDER: Well--
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: So tell
us, aside from finances,
like how's the care that
this population is getting?
ERIC SCHNEIDER: --yeah, so
I want to turn to that now.
But first I want to say
it's great to be back here.
I've taught at the school and
done research here since 1997,
and joined the Commonwealth
Fund four years ago.
It's exciting to be
working with Bob again,
and to see so many colleagues
and friends in the audience.
What I want to turn to
next on the next slide is
this issue that really
dates back to my arrival
at the Harvard School
of Public Health,
which was the Institute of
Medicine began to publish
a series of three reports--
To Err is Human, about safety,
Crossing the Quality Chasm,
about the quality
of care, and Report
on Disparities, racial and
ethnic disparities in care.
And that's 20 years ago now,
and what our survey has revealed
is that, for this
population, we've
actually made remarkably
little progress
in tackling some of
the problems that
were outlined in those reports.
The other thing I wanted to
mention here is that about 56%
of this group has emotional
problems, anxiety,
or depression attributable
to their illness.
And people who may not
have started out that way
often fall into a
sort of vicious circle
on that front, as
well as the financial.
So the next-- sorry, this slide
shows that about 61% of people
in this population experience
one or more problems that we
identify, that actually were
identified by the original
Institute of Medicine
report as problems--
poor care coordination, a lack
of clarity about services,
and a lack of
responsiveness of staff
to the needs of those people.
And you can see that
those range-- you know,
it's one in five
or one in four who
are experiencing each
of those, or reporting
each of those issues.
The other issue that comes up
on this slide is patient safety.
23% of the people
in this survey are
reporting that they experienced
serious medical errors.
That's a high rate.
Not entirely unexpected because
it's a complex population,
but we have to probably
do better on that.
So I'll take the next slide.
I'm just going to sort of pivot
to the solution side of this,
and give a little frame in
terms of our conclusions
about what's needed here.
And this is really
based on the needs
that patients
experienced and reported.
Up until the last 20
years, many people
have focused more on the
delivery system side.
And as I just said, the
delivery system side
is not doing what
it needs to do.
But this survey was an
attempt to actually report
on the user needs,
the experience
of these vulnerable populations.
So the first strategy, area of
strategies, that we identified
is the issue of building
behavioral health capacity
to manage behavioral
health needs of this really
challenged population.
The second is the issue
of assessing and then
addressing the social
needs that people
have-- housing, transportation,
nutritional needs.
Those are unmet in many in
our survey, for many people.
The third is to
make coordination
of care a priority.
People talk about
care coordination.
There have been a
lot of federal effort
to try to bring about care
coordination in the system.
But there really is
still a high level
of reporting that the
care is not coordinated,
and that primary
care in particular
is not able to solve this
problem yet for most people.
And then the fourth
is the issue of making
care more affordable to avoid
the sort of vicious cycle
that Bob pointed out.
So with that, I'm going to
turn it over to Bob Master.
BOB MASTER: Thank you.
So what I think I
can talk about is
what about all of
these issues in people
with additional challenges?
Low income challenges,
what we now
call social determinants
of health challenges,
and people who in fact probably
have the best insurance
you can have when you put
Medicare and Medicaid together.
You don't have the
financial issues,
but you have a care
delivery system
that is hopelessly
in need of redesign
to more effectively
provide care.
So what are the
clinical characteristics
of this population?
And it's heterogeneous, but
clearly, as we talked about,
you have one or more
significant chronic illnesses
that have very low thresholds
to hospitalization.
And we'll come back
to the hospital part,
because that's a part
of the downward spiral.
You have very high
prevalence of people
that have long-term service
and support needs, that are not
fully independent and
may be fully dependent
and everything
along the spectrum.
And whether that's a frail
elder or whether that's
a younger person,
or even a child
or adolescent with significant
disabilities, that adds to it.
As Eric said, behavioral
health prevalence
is extraordinarily high,
and integration is just
the beginning.
What is really
needed, and if we're
going to prevent
that downward spiral
of recurrent
hospitalizations, 95%
through the emergency room
because of the low thresholds,
and each of the spiral
leads to more transitions--
it's in the transitions
where you have
the problems and the errors--
you're going to need an
absolute redesign of what
is done in addition to
the need for coordination.
It isn't coordinating
all the pieces here,
we have to change what is
happening in those pieces.
And we can talk
about that later.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: Toyin,
I know you guys at CityBlock
are treating this
population who are
facing both these
medical and some
of these financial challenges.
Can you just talk
to us a little bit
about how it looks
close to the ground?
TOYIN AJAYI: Sure.
And first just to
commend you all,
thank you so much
for this research.
It's just so important
to start to quantify
how significant these financial
barriers can be for people
with serious illness.
It gives voice and
data to what we
see in our clinical practice.
And I think the
key things to note
in real life, the
population that we're
serving is that this manifests
both in the financial burden
that you articulated, but also
in a whole host of continually
hidden costs, cost
to the patient
and to the family
that are essentially
invisible to the
health care system.
And so when I see my
patients in practice,
not only do we ask
about and do we
see the financial costs of care
in the form of particularly
pharmaceutical costs, but
also have to pay attention
to the opportunity costs.
And so when you're talking
about a population of folks
like the folks who we
serve, who have insurance--
and by and large,
as Bob described,
this is probably the best
insurance you can get.
It's Medicaid, or it's
Medicare, or it's both.
These are folks, though,
for whom their time is one
of the most valuable assets.
And what we don't capture
yet is the opportunity cost
of being seriously ill.
So you're asking people
to take time off work.
If they're working, that's
cash out of their pockets.
If they're an
hourly wage worker,
it's pretty significant.
We're asking people to
pay for transportation
to get to the appointment.
We're asking people to pay for
child care while they're sick
or while they're accessing
additional services.
That recurrent cycle continues
to exacerbate the costs
in that household.
Additionally, as some folks have
already started to describe,
the barriers to addressing
all of the other needs
a person has in their
home and in their life
in order to access effective
medical care can be huge.
If you're trying to make a
decision between whether you
pay $400 for a copay for your
insulin or if you're behind
on all of your other bills--
your rent, your utility bills--
it's understandable why
people make rational decisions
not to access health care.
And yet to the providers
in the health care system,
we know that often asking
people about financial burdens
in their lives is taboo.
We feel like our job is to
provide the best medical care
and the best medical
recommendations
regardless of our
ability to pay,
and regardless of
people's incomes.
So recognizing that your
financial status plays
a role in health and
well-being is something
that doctors typically
aren't trained to do,
and it's something that the
health care system is not
oriented to do.
We find that, in our population,
not asking those questions
should be tantamount
to medical malpractice,
because if you're asking someone
to do something that means
they don't feed their children
or clothe their children,
or asking them to make
choices and take time out
of their day in ways
that disadvantage
them in other parts of their
lives, we are doing them harm.
And we need to be really
cognizant of that, as well.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
So in a moment,
I want to talk more
about solutions
to try to improve
some of these problems
that we have
identified, but first I
want another video clip
about a program that
is trying to do that, called
the Guided Care program.
And this clip comes from
the Commonwealth Fund.
SPEAKER 2: When we have
a doctor's appointment,
she'll go there with us.
And she'll sit there and listen
to what the doctor has to say.
SPEAKER 3: It's been
wonderful having her.
Gives me a sense of security.
SPEAKER 4: I think
the biggest challenges
they face medically
is just trying
to be as healthy as they
can within their limiting
conditions.
As a guided care
nurse, what I try to do
is give them ways to
feel more confident,
and to have them do their own
health care or their own med
setup, but then double
check to give them
that comfort that they know
they're doing it right.
Part of my role is seeing
them in their homes,
going to office
visits with them,
doing telephone
calls in between.
Yeah, hi, this is Patti.
I'm just calling to see how your
medication is working for you.
We found that guided
care really helps
in those transitional
areas, because that
tends to be when patients
will fall through the cracks.
If the patient is hospitalized,
I see them at the hospital.
If they're discharged to the
nursing home, I go there.
My biggest role is to guide
them through wherever they are,
be it at home, at the
office, at the hospital,
and make sure that their
care is transitioned
and there's no errors made.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
So Eric, I'm curious,
you obviously know the most
about this particular program.
And I'm wondering
whether you think
this program or other
programs like it
can start to make a dent
in some of the problems
that we've just
been talking about.
ERIC SCHNEIDER: Yeah.
I would love to get Bob and
Toyin's opinion on this, too,
but it really does
illustrate the need
to move care into the home-based
setting, into the community,
as much as possible.
We really haven't pushed the
envelope in terms of that.
And I think I just want to
reiterate Bob's point that--
this Bob--
[LAUGHTER]
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: I
know, we're surrounded.
ERIC SCHNEIDER: --that it's
not enough to coordinate
the existing building
blocks of the system.
We really actually need
to innovate and redesign
the care to deliver
it in the home
to address a lot of the other
issues that one can see.
I've done home
visits, one can see
these issues that will never
come up in a clinic setting.
And so I think that's
really important.
BOB MASTER: I can start.
By the way, I
think after working
with Toyin for
over six years, we
can complete each
other's sentences.
[LAUGHTER]
And maybe we should do this
as a team without question.
But if we just look at
those building blocks--
first of all, what are
the redesign elements?
And I really do want to start
with the extraordinary work
that was really done
as part of the ACA
to really try to scale a
systems of care and change
that really was neglected
for decades ever
since the onset of
Medicare and Medicaid.
And that was the beginning
of global payments
where a clinical organization
with the appropriate risk
adjustment could have complete
responsibility over all
of the benefits and services
of medical care, hospital
care, pharmacy,
and long-term care
that you could
bring to a person.
And that allows you
to re-imagine care.
So fee for service,
piecemeal care
where a physician in an office
is seeing people in 15 minute
visits don't work.
And the next thing that
is really required in that
is to re-imagine primary care.
And that would be not just a
doctor in an office, and not
just 3% to 4% of the
total medical spend
going to primary
care, but in fact,
an interdisciplinary team
that may look different
for different populations.
And that would be the doctor,
the nurse practitioner
for people with
physical disabilities,
integrated physical therapy
and occupational therapy,
and durable medical equipment
for the integrated behavioral
health to reiterate
the importance of that
in practices.
And you're now then
talking about 10% to 12%
of the pie that has
to go to primary care.
And until we resource
that correctly,
and until we move to global
payment arrangements,
you're not going to
be able to do that.
You then have to build
what we call elasticity
into the system in primary care.
Toyin and I go to
work in the morning.
Most physicians are booked
from 8:00 in the morning
until who knows
when in the evening.
And yet, if you have
people with low thresholds
to problems that
are going to occur,
how do they receive that care?
In the United States today, it's
the ambulance and the emergency
room.
So thinking about elasticity.
If you have a
frail elder at home
or a person with
disabilities, you've
got to get that
assessment and you've
got to move it into the home.
In fact, for people with
physical disabilities
who rely on the
publicly funded ride,
they can't get to
a doctor's office
immediately because you
got to have a 24 to 48
hour appointment
window to do that.
So it's now primary care as
a service and not a building.
And seeing people as needed
and not by appointment.
And then comes the
second and third stage.
How do we then move into
what we call the primary care
whitespace, which is
what happens after hours
when somebody is sick
and a physician takes
that call at midnight,
and you can't figure out
whether this can
take two aspirins
and we'll see you tomorrow
or you're really sick,
we got to get you in now.
Most of it falls in
the middle where you
don't know what's happening.
And by default, this
frail elder or a person
with risk for hospitalizations
goes to the emergency room.
What do you do there in
terms of system change?
And there is some interesting
work with advanced life support
clinicians that can do
this kind of response
as part of a primary care team.
And the last-- and
I'll stop here--
is the redesign of how you care
for people in the hospital.
In one sentence, you're moving
primary care and continuity
into the hospital.
And so when a person needs it,
they've got their teams there.
And I'll stop.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: So Toyin,
I see a lot of nodding.
TOYIN AJAYI: So much nodding.
[LAUGHTER]
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
I'm curious, as you
think about these opportunities
for improving coordination
for this population
that's really sick.
People have a lot
of illnesses who
have been hospitalized a lot,
who have lot of medical needs.
Are the strategies--
do they carry over
to those of us who
are normally healthy,
but maybe have a crisis
every once in a while?
Or does it feel like
a unique problem
that needs a unique
set of situations?
I'm just wondering how much
is this a good metaphor?
If we figured out how
to solve these people,
then we're going to
translate it over here.
How much of it is, OK,
let's just do one thing here
and one thing there.
TOYIN AJAYI: I think it's
a really great question.
So the way that
we have typically
used innovation in
health care in particular
has been that we've
solved for the healthy.
If you think about the
typical primary care model,
for example, it works
great if you're in your 20s
and you don't have a
lot of medical needs,
and you can afford
to take time off work
to go see a primary care
doctor, and you can wait,
and you can come back,
and pay the copay,
and get your once
a year physical.
It works fine.
It's not perfect.
It could be better,
but it works fine.
And the innovation
in primary care
largely has been to try to
make that interaction more
seamless for people who
are relatively healthy
and have resources.
That doesn't work.
It's not going to trickle
down to people who are sick.
It's not going to
trickle down to people
with complex needs
for all of the reasons
that Bob described when
you talk about the 24/7
nature of their need for access
to high quality health care.
That said, however, any single
one of us who is healthy today
is, as we know, a unfortunate
accident, a catastrophe,
an undiagnosed cancer
away from being sick.
And the data from
this study shows
that if that happens, no
matter where you start,
if you're insured or not,
the risk that that pushes you
into poverty is so great.
So suddenly, we have
a frame in which
the safety net system that
we're building actually
may serve any one of us.
Any person in this country
who is going to age
and be sick over time,
which as the population ages
and as we start to prevent more
and more diseases until later
into our adulthood, is
going to be most of us.
As we got into our 60s
and 70s, the likelihood
that we're living with chronic
conditions is incredibly high.
And the likelihood
that one of those
makes us have to seek hospital
care and expensive drug
treatments that push us into
poverty is also quite high.
But when we build solutions,
we have to build intensely
for that population.
And the lessons will
trickle up, if you will,
to people who are less sick
who need less of the services.
They may require
fewer of the tools
in the toolkit in a much
less frequent fashion.
But we need to have
them there because it
could be any one of us.
And so when we think about
really focusing innovation,
putting together
the best teams we
can around technology, around
operational design, logistics,
24/7 access to care, [INAUDIBLE]
in service of this use case.
Our hypothesis,
though, is that as we
start to push those
tools out, they
will become in service of folks
who are less needed today,
but over time they
become high risk.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
I just wanted
to make sure that we
circled back to Bob's slides
about some of the
financial stresses
that people face because those
really did stick out to me.
And I feel they connect to a
growing body of research that
shows that not only
are we seeing more
people with insurance that has
high cost sharing that exposes
them to a lot of out-of-pocket
costs even if they are insured,
but also growing
evidence that being sick
has other financial consequences
for people because if you can't
work-- even if you
don't lose your job,
if you have to take time
off, you have to cut back
on your hours, if you have
disability that makes it
hard to do the
same kind of work,
that losing income can be an
additional financial challenge
associated with being sick.
And so I'm just wondering
how should we think
about this group of problems?
Is health insurance good enough?
What can we do to
make it better?
Do we need other kinds of wrap
around insurance for people
so that when they get sick they
don't get pushed into poverty
as Toyin described?
ROBERT BLENDON: So I'm
going to surprise you.
I'm not going to say
it's all very complex.
[LAUGHTER]
So first, all you have to do
is turn on the TV, and look,
we're now in the Medicare
enrollment choice.
And it says, pick the Medicare
wrap around that you need.
The first thing
out of this survey
is very few people knew three
years ahead that they would
have five hospitalizations,
$50,000 of drug bills,
five doctors.
They had no idea.
And we're telling
them to choose a plan.
Now how can I be
insured and have
$50,000 of prescription drugs?
That's easy.
I bought a drug benefit.
Except somebody gave me a
drug for cancer or something,
and that little drug
benefit won't do that.
And so we're having a
debate for the under 65.
Let's choose the plan you need.
There's no reason that you
should have requirements.
Same thing happened.
A young adult
choosing has no idea
they're getting hit by a
car or have a heart attack.
And so they don't know.
So what do we need simply is not
what it appears on television.
Get yourself a counselor to read
the 47 pages of the Medicare
alternatives.
No, there has to be a federal
or state agency that certifies.
Very simple.
A little star.
If you buy this plan,
it will cover you
for your catastrophic illnesses.
You don't have to read
the other 47 pages.
And it probably is
going to have to extend
coverage that isn't there.
You should not require
people to have to figure out,
will my cancer be a type one?
And that will be covered
fully by the policy,
but a type two isn't fully.
You're not going to know that.
So a nice little star
says, don't worry,
when the ambulance
comes and you're there,
you have a policy
that will cover it.
We have no certification.
Likewise, we need a catastrophic
something for work-related days
off benefits.
At some point, it kicks back in.
And if you really are caring for
somebody needs a lot of care,
your job has some
protection that after 14
days of sick days,
they don't fire you.
And it has to be a requirement
where it kicks in way down.
But those two things,
an easy certification.
But please, the
people we surveyed
could not read a 37
page choice document.
And that ad which says
we'll get you a reaper
and we'll work your way
through, that's exactly what
is not needed.
What's needed is a
simple certification that
says, if this happens to you--
and by the way, if we told you
we were giving a drug benefit,
the company can't say I'm not
going to pay for this drug.
It's just not fair to people.
They have no way of
knowing that they're going
to have to have a prescription.
So this is simple, but
I'm a tenured professor.
[LAUGHTER]
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: That
sounds like an expensive system
what you're describing.
ROBERT BLENDON: That's why he
does costs and I do protection.
[LAUGHTER]
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
Do any of you
other guys have
thoughts about that?
About this cost problem?
ROBERT MASTER: Very briefly,
I have to respond now
that I am a Medicare
beneficiary myself
and having gone through this.
And I think I know
more about this world
than most people having
lived it for decades.
I won't say how many.
And this policy decade.
And it was opaque.
Absolutely opaque in saying
which drug plan do you pick?
Which wrap around
Medigap do you pick?
And I'm saying, oh, my god,
if it's that opaque for me,
how is it for
people that are not
in health care in this world?
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: I would say
that's the most common email
that I get from
colleagues or friends.
Can you help me select
between these options?
TOYIN AJAYI: If I could
just add one thing.
This is the quintessential
of market failure, right?
There is such a lack of
information available to people
that are making these choices.
And I think what just
adds insult to injury
is that this data is available.
And actually, it's
being used, I would
argue, not for good
by other agents,
but in the health care system.
So you think that health
insurance plans can
tell by your purchasing
patterns, your demographics,
and where you live
the likelihood of you
becoming seriously ill
in the next five years.
And they do use this to
try to figure out where
they should market their plans.
They want to the healthiest
people on their Medicare
Advantage plans.
Large retail stores
know exactly when
you are likely to have a
need for x or y product.
And that's when miraculously
the ad shows up on your iPhone
or the flyer comes
through your mailbox.
We have the data to
help people better
understand what their risks
are and what the likelihood
that they're going to
need catastrophic coverage
and how they should be
prioritizing their resources.
So even just giving
more transparency
to that information, some
guiding, some coaching.
And then I love the idea
of certifying plans.
That when you know
you're buying something,
you know what you
can expect from it.
It's such a fundamental
thing I think
we can do to help people, in
addition to all of the work
that we need to do to put
pressure on on the broader
systems to really ask
what coverage you need
and what our commitment
to ensuring that when
we say people have
insurance that they really
have insurance.
It feels like there's almost a
nomenclature gap here as well
because we're not seeing
quite the same thing when
we say you have
coverage and then
we find out that actually
your out-of-pocket costs
are through the roof
and you had no idea.
ERIC SCHNEIDER: Yeah,
just to put a number
on this, the Commonwealth
Fund survey which
tracks the adequacy
of health insurance--
the under-insured
rate, people who
really are facing unmanageable
costs in any given year
has gone up to nearly half the
general population, let alone
this very vulnerable population.
The other thing I
just wanted to say
is that we've been now 20
years into a cycle of consumer
information and transparency
that would somehow allow people
to make good choices and
create the incentives
for organizations.
And many people are starting
to conclude that that's not
a successful strategy, or
at least not sufficient
to solve some of these problems.
So what we have now is
people with insurance
facing high deductibles,
facing ruinous costs.
And that's colliding
with a system that
has consolidated where costs
are escalating dramatically
where the prices are
really out of control
because there's no
counter negotiating power.
And from a policy level, that's
a really important issue.
If people can work
on that, we would
be delighted to talk
to you after this.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
So we're just
about at the time for questions.
So I'm going to
start with a question
that we received through
our email system.
But all of you
guys, you're next.
So get ready.
And this is a question
that gets back
to the caregiver issue,
which I was hoping
we were going to touch on.
What can we do in
terms of policy change
to help caregivers,
like family and friends,
manage the stress and
responsibility of helping
ill patients once they get home?
So many patients
need support when
they return from the hospital,
and workplace policies
in particular make it
difficult for family and others
to provide coverage.
So there was a
lot of information
in this survey about caregivers,
about the financial stresses
that we saw in Bob's slide.
But also just how hard it
is emotionally for them
and how much work it is to
care for their relatives.
And so I'm curious what
thoughts you guys have
about that, about what we could
do better for those people.
ERIC SCHNEIDER: I'll just say--
I meant to say this earlier
that the Commonwealth
Fund has teamed with
five other foundations.
The Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation, the Peterson
Foundation, the SCAN
foundation, Hartford Foundation,
and Millbank Foundation to
create a digital resource,
which you saw a clip from,
called the Better Care
Playbook.
And the purpose of that
is to really feature
evidence-based
interventions that
could be helpful to
people with complex needs.
And caregiver support comes
up over and over again.
And we saw that
in the clip there.
ROBERT MASTER:
Again, some lessons
from the Medicaid world.
Medicaid really was our
nation's first long-term care
and disability insurer
for support care.
And maybe it is the
only comprehensive one.
One of the most
important supports
was personal care assistance.
Self-directed personal
care assistance,
which was a unique
Medicaid benefit that
grew up over decades, and,
at in least in the more
recent iterations that Toyin
and I have been involved in,
was the opportunity
to essentially
have family members, whether
it's a spouse, whether it's
a daughter, son, granddaughter,
grandson, nephew, neighbor,
friend, be that
caregiver and reimbursed.
And you say, well,
how can you do that?
Well, in some ways, how
can you not do that?
Because the cost of having
some reasonable reimbursement
for that kind of support
is the alternative
to a skilled nursing
facility in many cases.
Or worse, for many
frail elders, more
of a long-term nursing facility
at several hundred dollars
a day.
And so are the lessons
from the Medicaid world?
And historically,
Medicaid was always
viewed as the marginalized
twin to Medicare.
But in fact, has been this
engine of policy innovation.
And that's a good example.
And is that applicable to
the more broad and general
population?
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
So what would the idea
be that your health insurance
benefits should include
some stipend for someone
who takes care of you
if you have a really
serious problem?
ROBERT MASTER: And you
don't have a Medicaid card?
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: Right.
ROBERT MASTER: Yeah, possibly.
And it may be very
cost effective
in the investment in that.
Absolutely.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
Any other thoughts?
TOYIN AJAYI: The other
thing I would add
is-- and it's not quite
responsive to the question
because it's not
as much a policy
lever as it is a
care model lever is
thinking about social care.
And so we at City
Block really focus
on going beyond
screening and referral
for social determinants,
but thinking
about social components of
care as a whole thick piece
of the puzzle.
And that means asking both who
do you depend on for supports?
Physical practical,
tangible supports as well as
emotional supports.
And also, who depends on you?
And recognizing
that every person
is part of a complex ecosystem
of relationships that sometimes
make them dependent on
another and other times
allow them to be the
support person for others.
If we ask those
questions as a matter
of routine in all of our
health care interactions
everywhere in the system,
than it necessarily behooves
us try to act on those.
And so when you think
about people going home
from the hospital, if it was
the business of the health care
system to know that your
daughter is the person who
really supports you in
getting dressed every morning
and that she's just taken a new
job out of town or something,
then we're able to start to
think about what it looks
like for your discharge
home and what other supports
we would need to put in place.
Versus the converse,
recognizing that if we
have patients, individuals
who are also carers,
because we can be both.
We can be seriously ill,
dependent on others,
and also carers for others.
The impact on the whole
ecosystem around you
can be profound.
So what we're
finding in particular
when we think about cost is that
interventions on social care
are cheaper in general
and accrue returns
across a larger number of people
than a health care intervention
where you treat a patient and
that patient derives benefit.
If you're thinking
about, for example,
food insecure individuals.
If I had a senior who
didn't have enough food, who
was dependent on their
daughter or granddaughter
to help make sure
they ate every day
and we worked with
them to make them
less dependent on
that family member,
we've actually
unlocked capabilities
across the whole family.
And that's really a powerful
set of interventions.
And so thinking
about social care
both as an understanding
of what people
social abilities,
their needs are,
and then addressing
those just as you
would any other part of
their health care needs
can be a really powerful
way to start to address
the burden on caregivers.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: Do we
have any audience questions?
Yes, right here.
If we can get a microphone.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
Thank you so much for what
you guys have shared so far.
So I'm Brian Buckley, a
second year DrPH student.
And so you've
talked a little bit
about the aspect of
social care and how
care's really expanding outside
the four walls of the hospital.
I'm interested in the role of
TeleHealth and home-based care.
And where do you see it
both on the opportunity cost
side of things,
but also reducing
financial costs and
different reimbursements that
can go with that?
TOYIN AJAYI: Bob,
you have to start.
ROBERT MASTER: I was going to
say the same thing about you.
TOYIN AJAYI: I
learned everything
that I know about
this at this speech.
So I could never.
ROBERT MASTER:
There is no question
that I think that if you
enable a clinical clinician
with TeleHealth ability to
actually access the home,
that's a step up.
The concern I have is where
the love affair with technology
is a replacement
for the care system.
I think it's an enabler and an
enhancement to a care system.
But it really still starts
with that home-based personal
capacity.
How do we move primary
care into the home?
How do we have a
response to new problems?
How do we allocate the right
amount of long term services
and support services
that are needed?
And then TeleHealth clearly,
I think, can enhance that.
But in and of itself,
without a system redesign,
I have problems.
I don't know, what
do you think Tory?
TOYIN AJAYI: I agree.
I mean, of course I agree 100%.
I mean, I think going back to
the foundational principles
of what we're trying to solve
for, when we have people
with serious illness
with multiple competing
concerns, who also either in
addition to and before they
became seriously ill,
or as a consequence
of the serious illness, are also
struggling with social needs,
that home visit and
that home-based care
is just catalytic in two ways.
One, I think the
questioner asked
about kind of the opportunity
cost, and that's huge.
It's moving people from
the whole cycle of getting
into a clinic multiple
times, sometimes even
multiple times a
week, saves them time
and allows them to do other
things, which is important.
But there's also
foundational kind
of values and trust
building exercise
that happens when human
being from the care system
steps foot in
their patients home
that is just
incredibly powerful.
It re-balances the
patient-provider relationship.
You know as a physician
going into a patient's home,
I wait for them.
I see them on their own terms.
I am humbled in their presence,
which is really important when
I think that this is a
person I want to call me
instead of going to
the emergency room
when they're feeling sick.
They need to trust me.
And you don't trust
somebody who you
don't feel like
you can relate to,
who you don't feel
like is there for you,
and who doesn't listen to you.
And so being able to just
establish that foundation
is so powerful.
What we found is that
if you layer TeleHealth
on top of that
trusted relationship,
you unlock a ton of potential
for the ease of 24/7 access
and for the ability
to operationally
kind of scale its type of
very human-centered approach.
And we do that a couple of ways.
One is following a series
of really in-depth,
in-person conversations with
members of the care team,
we find that our patients are
much more likely to than video
in, or tele-visit, or
text us, or call us
when they're having needs.
The other thing that we
think is really interesting
is allowing a different
member of the care team--
we've talked about
interdisciplinary teams.
Bob Master talked
about this earlier,
but really thinking
about the power
of non-clinically licensed
individuals on a care team.
At Cityblock, we use
community health partners.
These are folks who are
not clinically licensed.
They're hired from the
communities that we serve.
They are hired for empathy,
and for listening skills,
and for trust building.
And they go into
a patient's home
and say, hey, it sounds
like that wound on your leg
isn't looking so great.
What if we just video the doctor
in right now to look at that?
They're facilitating
that interaction
that allows the doctor to be
more efficient with their time,
but still has that
human contact.
And using those
individuals in the trust
that they build with our
patients and our community
members as a bridge to
the health care system
is also incredibly powerful.
So I agree, I think technology
has to be part of the solution,
but it does not
function particularly
in this population with
absent, really solid
trusted human relationships.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: So
we have another question
that's come by email.
Has the Affordable
Care Act helped people
with serious illness?
If so, in what ways?
And are there policy
changes happening now
or threats to the
ACA that could be
important in changing those
improvements if they exist?
ROBERT BLENDON:
So we can't answer
that because no one's been
tracking this group of people.
Obviously, we covered a lot
of people with insurance
and the benefits went up.
What's staggering here, the
people we're interviewing
are post ACA.
Good news, you have no problems.
So they have the
post ACA benefits.
And I'm looking at
this and saying,
wow, what could
have been before?
So the answer is whatever we
have done have really protected
people without insurance.
But this crowd of very seriously
ill people with insurance
are not being protected.
You can have these
scale bills for that.
But coming out of the
world competition,
and I love competition,
but this idea
choose what you need is a very
dangerous assumption coming out
of this, cause you
just don't know
what it's going to work out.
And I think post ACA, the
fact that so many people--
I have a drug benefit,
it's protecting me--
you're paying $50,000 a year.
So we didn't do a
particularly good job
of guaranteeing that that
prescription that you think
your physician absolutely has
to have is in your drug benefit.
But this could be fixed.
But we have not followed
this group of people.
What we mostly just
follow is general public.
They are better off,
particularly if you've
got insurance coverage.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
The ACA coverage
has out-of-pocket
maximums, right?
So people who are facing
$50,000 in drug coverage
are probably in Medicare, right?
I guess they have a
catastrophic benefit, too.
ROBERT BLENDON: The answer
is half our people said
they had to pay it themselves.
So what is necessary,
and that's why
I don't think individuals
should have to do this,
is to get a sample of people
and go through their bills,
and were I've been told
I've been guaranteed
by the federal
government, and I'm
paying thousands of thousands
of dollars out for this.
So what we think we
guaranteed, if you
look at these
people's experiences,
doesn't actually
work out that way.
But we can't answer it
now, because actually we
didn't think the problem
would be that severe.
We didn't go up and say, can you
describe each bucket of bills
that you have?
But somehow, this
catastrophic feature
is not protecting these
people or they wouldn't
have those substantial bills.
ERIC SCHNEIDER: One thing that
I mentioned is the sort of 65
and under group who are
not Medicare eligible
now have protection against
pre-existing conditions.
That was a big problem
in health insurance
market prior to the ACA.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: Please
explain what that is.
ERIC SCHNEIDER: Sorry,
yes, so it used to be.
It may still be under some of
the ACA non-compliant health
plans that you
can have insurance
and the insurer can decide
that because you have
a preexisting
condition, and that
could be a lot of
different things,
and certainly these
folks are going
to have preexisting conditions
by the insurance definition,
they could either refuse
to renew your insurance
or they could raise
the price to the point
where you couldn't
afford the premium,
or raise the deductible or use
other financial machinations.
And so the reversal
and the uninsured rate
that brought about by
the ACA is, in big part,
because people who
couldn't get insurance
in the prior pre-ACA world now
can get insurance coverage.
They still may have problems,
but certainly they're
not just sort of abandoned
on the street, uninsured
using public facilities
if they do that.
ROBERT MASTER: Just
to add, I think
the ACA has been an
unmitigated blessing
and it has a long way to go.
But if we add to what
talking about with people
with preexisting
conditions, in the ACA
there was a provision for
the Center for Medicare
and Medicaid Innovation.
And substantially funded.
And a good example of
the kind of innovations
were really very, very
relevant to the populations
that we're talking about.
And that example
is, among others,
was Mount Sinai Hospital that
looked at its frail elder
Medicare beneficiaries that
were identified as what we call
in health care frequent flyers,
back and forth, back and forth,
back and forth to the hospital
because the system just wasn't
organized for their care.
And in fact, many of the
issues of hospital care
made things worse in terms
of drug-resistant organisms
and the like, and transitions
for skilled nursing facilities.
And so the idea of could we
take a pre-identified population
with complex chronic
illness, low thresholds
to these hospitalizations, and
think about a different path
for them.
And it started out
a different path
through the emergency room,
and maybe an infirmary bed.
But where it evolved in the
second iteration in 2014,
and this is just one
example, is maybe
we don't need to
hospitalize them
at all if we can put all the
components of hospital care
at home for this frail elder
and think about what that
does to the transitions
and all of the risks
around transitions.
And that, again, is
the kind of thing
that did not happen
systematically
prior to the ACA.
And the benefits will not
accrue on any scale maybe
for another five to eight years.
But I am predicting a Medicare
bundled payment for a hospital
at home DRG then is
paid to hospital today
and the potential transfer of
substantial numbers of patients
that are on our
medical floors today
to home-based care in
a handful of years.
TOYIN AJAYI: Yeah, I
wouldn't say much more except
to echo that I think in the
spirit of Bob's comment,
a ton of innovation
has occurred,
some catalyzed by CMMI and
by the dual demonstrations,
the demonstrations
that allow integration
of Medicare and Medicaid
plans for people
who are duly eligible.
Those have both, I think,
informed and shaped
an emerging generation,
I think, of leaders
within that kind of health
care transformation.
I would consider
myself one of those.
As well as starting to
contribute to our published
literature on what works for
taking care of populations
with complex needs,
even a lexicon
around who those folks
are, how you identify them.
And then what types of care,
including hospital and home,
including community
para-medicine models,
including complex
care management,
interdisciplinary
care teams, all
of the principles that we
bring to the work that we do
have had a chance to
be baked and germinated
through an innovation process.
And it is a remarkable
moment in time
when we can say collectively as
a community, we have a problem.
And this problem is both
access and the quality of care
that we provide to people
who really need it.
And we're going to try to
throw a whole bunch of things
at the wall, see what sticks.
And this is the point
in which we're really
asking, well, how do we
scale what we know works now?
It's a very different point in
time than where we were even,
you know, seven or eight years
ago when we didn't really
know what worked.
We know what works now.
And folks like myself and
others across the country
is saying, all right, well
how do put this on steroids
so we scale it to all
the people who need it.
It's a very different problem,
but it comes very much out
of the legacy of so
much of the work that
has been done at places
like Commonwealth Care
Alliance and others.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
I think we have
time for one more
audience question
if someone has a good one.
Oh, sorry, I've made
the pressure too high.
AUDIENCE: Hello
thank you so much.
My name is Raven Bachan.
I'm a master's in
public health student
and I'm also a medical
student at home.
And sometimes it feels like
these conversations are often
in the public health world
but not often brought
to the academic medical world.
So I was just
wondering what you see
as the role of
academic health centers
in training our future
physicians to have
these sort of values, whether
it's the education on how
to have these conversations
with their patients
or shifting the norm of bringing
primary care to the homes,
and how we can hold
the academic medicine
centers accountable for
assisting in these goals?
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: What
a great last question.
ERIC SCHNEIDER: That's
wonderful question.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
So I want to just flag
as you guys think about
your answers the thing
that Toyin said early on
about how clinicians often
don't ask their patients
about the financial aspects
of their care in addition
to their clinical aspects
of their care.
ERIC SCHNEIDER: So having
practiced and taught
in a local academic
medical center
for many years,
primary care, I have
to confess that as I was
doing my research going out
into the field looking at
other primary care practices,
I discovered that academic
medical centers are often
the least interested in change.
They've been the slowest to pick
up some of these challenges.
I'm saying it in sort
of a blanket way.
It's not entirely true.
But I've started
to see that change,
the Association of
Academic Medical Colleges,
has taken on the innovation
agenda of something
they want to teach.
And I think the piece
that's always been missing
is the desire to do
interdisciplinary training
and the need to design
interdisciplinary training so
that the teams learn how
to function, especially
for patients like this.
ROBERT MASTER:
Just very quickly,
one of my mentors
when I was younger,
Jack Geiger had
this saying, trying
to teach the principles of
personalized coordinated
primary care in an
academic medical center
is like trying to teach
the principles of forestry
in a lumber yard.
Now, that was back then.
And it's come away.
But I think I have
to say I don't
think that's the
place we're going
to see these kind of changes.
TOYIN AJAYI: I'm going to have
to double down on that one.
I think we need a radical
overhaul of what we believe
our role is as
physicians and the voice
that we give to patients.
And how we interact with other
members of the care team,
how we value them, and
how we interact with them,
I think, is really hard to teach
in the proverbial ivory tower
where academic
medicine continues
to be such a hierarchy
and continues
to privilege research and
specialization over what, you
know, I believe in as
the kind of foundation
of a good primary
care, which is humility
and partnership with
community members
and patients and
their advocates,
and a willingness to not
have all the answers,
and understanding that
you can't fix everything,
and the patients to walk
with people on their path
to better health.
I think it is still
the case that folks
who enter those types
of institutions looking
for that type of
an experience often
find their way out of the
academic medical center.
And I actually think
that the folks who
are going to force this to
come to a head in the big sort
of bastions of academic
medical education, I hope,
are going to be patients
and consumers who say,
I want something different
for my health care system.
I want to be able to get the
very best of new technology
in cancer care and
also to be made
to feel truly human in
every aspect of my life
in health care that
I interact with.
I want my specialist
who is a world renowned
X or Y to talk to my
primary care doctor
who knows what
really matters to me.
And I'm going to force that
to happen through advocacy
and through policy.
But largely, I hope patients
would vote with their feet
about where they go
and what they privilege
and what they value in
those relationships.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ:
So we're going
to end with sort of
a lightning round
where I'm going to ask each
of our panelists to tell us,
like a short sort
of take away lesson,
solution, something
that you think
emerges from this
conversation that you
want to keep thinking about
and you want our audience
to keep thinking about.
And Bob, can I start with you?
ROBERT BLENDON:
Yeah, I'm simple.
We need a independent rating
of policies which basically
gives you a star and says if
something terrible happens
to you, it will cover it.
I have very little use for
this physician information.
The average physician time
is 15 minutes with a patient.
There are 50 different
policies out there.
The doctor who's trying to
figure out what you should do
is not going to decide if
Aetna 5 or Blue Cross 4
is right for you.
But we need certifications.
Secondly, I got to defend
people who are at home.
We're sending everybody
home, and the people
who are answering us have
the thrill of their home
care new system being their
daughter, their spouse,
their brother, et cetera.
If we are going to
send these people home,
we'd better have Bob's system.
Because we have people who
have to cut back their lives
because mom is coming home.
I told you about this,
we're about to have
the largest population ever
in US history over age 65.
If you have a parent,
good news, in our study,
you are about to become
a primary caregiver.
And so unless we can put
Bob's type system in here,
we are not going to be
protecting a lot of people
as we send them home.
They need X hours of time.
So we need something that
protects those family members
and we need a certification
on an insurance policy.
And that is a public
responsibility.
I don't care if it's a
local fire department.
But somebody has
to put a stamp on
and say, don't worry
about the 54 pages.
It'll protect you if
you buy this policy.
ERIC SCHNEIDER: And
mine will be very short,
if you want innovations
and you're not finding them
in your local academic
medical center,
or wherever else
you're practicing,
bettercareplaybook.org is the
sixth foundation website where
we're collecting these
evidence-based innovations,
community health workers
with telemedicine,
CCET I believe is in there.
But there are a lot of
models of care growing up
outside of sort of
traditional academic centers
that are available to people.
ROBERT MASTER: And
very, very quickly.
You know through the decades
of my career, most or all
of the innovation tried to
occur on the insurance side.
Case management,
demand management,
disease management all failures.
I don't know how much money
was spent on all of that.
The name of the game is
care system redesign.
And it's a values redesign.
And Toyin really speaks to
it unbelievably, eloquently.
In fact, it's such a
pleasure to hear her.
And I actually see the
future of spreading Toyin--
force multiplying Toyin
across the country.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: All
right Toyin, take a bow.
TOYIN AJAYI: I think speaking
to aspiring clinicians, health
system leaders, or people
who are in that role,
I think that the name
of the game for me
is just ask patients, how much
is this going to cost you?
And every aspect of the word
cost, time, self-esteem,
social relationships,
dollar bills--
we have to the systemize asking,
because what we find here
is that if we don't
ask, we can't mitigate
and we can't intervene.
And then that
person who shows up,
who's not taking
their medications, who
gets labeled as non-compliant
is struggling with poverty.
And we can address that.
We just need to ask.
MARGOT SANGER-KATZ: I want
to thank our audience,
and also thank our great
panel, and all the people
wrote in with questions.
This has been really great.
I've learned some things.
I hope you all have too.
Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]